what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba hi
I'm John Humphrey we are going to watch
the latest trailer for Terminator dark
fate I put out a post on our community
page and I'm going out of town this is
9:45 p.m. that we are recording this I
leave at 5:00 a.m. have a roll in a
short film gonna be gone for three days
I felt all prepared and now I'm gonna go
there with a lack of sleep because I
gotta cover this trailer you know how we
do and I know that anything else that we
upload that we already prepped in
advance people be like why'd you put
this up not the Dark Fae trailer succumb
to pressure that's how I roll around
here anywho let's watch this my name is
Sarah Connor
there's always a calmer
supposed to be Judgment Day
water please
and I changed the future saved three
billion lives enough of a resume for you
you know the future
[Music]
dark fate
Oh outside the title
whoo-hoo the midair now
I never seen one like you before
almost human
enhance
she because I was her
[Music]
whoa I can see you're very upset I'm
going to help you protect the girl okay
[Music]
this terminators got person oh yeah I
love to see the shot of those two
[Music]
[Music]
I mean the action looks pretty awesome
people do all right John I got some
thoughts you got some [ __ ] justice
boss you got some thoughts gray I got
some thoughts let's hear those thoughts
well I think the action looks really
freaking cool it's a good thought it's
the best thing I think both these true
is not going for it this trailer is an
improvement or the last trailer that's
for sure I think though the expectation
of so much of this is following in the
terminator - footsteps dimming down that
expectation would be a good idea I see
us earmarks that remind me of Terminator
2 to a certain extent by of course Sarah
Connor with Arnold's Terminator he's
credited as The Terminator
IMDB so yeah you must be a terminator or
a parameters from the first film again
somehow yeah some big mislead or
whatever was there marketing their high
and maybe I don't know it doesn't really
matter and even with Gabriel Lunas
character like he is a different
Terminator he can clone himself it is a
little bit more like the liquid
Terminator but even that little moment
where he is impersonating some kind of
officer or soldiers and like that it
seems like he has a real personality
when the time calls for it reminds me a
lot of Robert Patrick totally to wear as
opposed to other people who played bad
terminators they play it like like
clearly they're clearly impersonating a
human you know yeah they're I'm like oh
yeah so many I made me question it for a
second if I go maybe he's a human or
something yeah it's the only one it
works for his Arnold somehow yeah like
he kind of has the same delivery for a
while before he learns more of an
emotional range but yeah that is a
really great nuance - yes link -
especially is that they do come across
like a person when they got it and
that's always part of the fun of the
best terminators I feel like is that's
what makes the horror that much more
impact
and that's what makes it exciting to see
a cool actor take on a terminator role
as to see what kind of you know acting
muscle they can flex on top of you cold
and
yes I am what you call a terminator
fanatic like I love Terminator 2 and The
Matrix are tied for my number one
favorite movies of all time you know
hearing that expectation of following
symmetry so it says I see that they're
taking plot points and certain you know
traits tonally this is not that like
I've just had to accept that especially
we're watching this trailer though I'm
like no this looks more like a really
cool action movie it does that it does
have that Menace that underlying tone
that grit I don't think is going to be
as present I could be wrong it is just
the trailer yeah I could be wrong right
now this literally looks like a big
giant ensemble and also you know the
whole thing whoever this girl is that
Mackenzie Davis is protecting she claims
to be an enhanced human and not a
terminator I don't know what that's all
about
that is like protecting young John
Connor there's three of them and then
you have I don't know Arnold and Linda
Hamilton passing the baton to those
three Karia Lee hope that this movie
does manage to justify itself and to
have all these pieces fit in an original
you know fluid way that doesn't scream
like Oh trends and stuff because like at
a trailers glance it's easy to do that
and partly here I thought back to
Terminator 2 and I was like okay well
part of that is you know the John Connor
gets a father figure and there's a
motional story there and then in this
trailer I was like okay so they're gonna
try and make like Sarah Connor like the
new mom of this family and then like
Arnold's gonna be kind of the dad and
they're all gonna protect this girl
together or something like I think like
a weird like animal and then that the
grandparents is what it looks yeah yeah
this feels more like way more like Sarah
Connors movie just yeah a lot points I
have an impression that Arnold probably
won't come in till halfway through the
movie former terminators farming farming
it's kind of the vibe I'm getting
everything about this trailer reminds me
of Terminator mixed with something else
it's just what is that something just
what is it yes it's always a different
something else for what for some strange
reason I'm thinking back to oblivion
like where he lives in the woods and
stuff and then like a little place and
I'm like yeah you mix that with the
Terminator it looks the same but he's a
little older I did think back also to
Terminator 2 in the sense this feels
more contained like some kind of Road
movie or like they have to get to
someplace specific and Terminator 2 does
have that aspect that I think has been
missing from
at least you know the past couple seek
well yeah this seems to be about it's
characters that I have a feeling that
Linda Hamilton will steal the show but I
think the heart of the movies probably
gonna be Mackenzie Davis yeah weirdly
the the one they're protecting doesn't
seem to really showcase her that much
she seems to be the new John Connor of
sorts yeah ever that role is no no
Edward Furlong he's right he's supposed
to be in this movie he's credited to be
in in this film Italia Reyes that's the
girl's name Yeah right okay the thing to
me is that this trailer gave us the
action that we glimpsed the first time
and it gave more breathing room for
characters to talk but I think the only
thing we really got out of this was that
the Terminator has a bit of personality
and that everybody else is you know in a
badass grim situation but we don't
really get any context as to much of the
intimate story or much of what the
characters are gonna be like when
they're just interacting it's like
nothing breathes as a scene so I feel
like that part is the big mystery and
that's the worrisome thing to me the
thing I hope they really nail and
they're just not you know maybe they
can't translate it here is yeah is this
gonna be just a glorified really cool
Terminator action movie with enough
story to get it by I feel like they're
gonna really the thing this really gave
me was a lot more character a lot more
emotion I was a little bit confused on
timeline-wise
those images of skull terminators and
skulls and then it's terminators in the
background is that another rendition
that we've seen a gajillion times of day
just like the different is that or that
or that the world were in now is that
the world today the vibe I got was maybe
the it's gonna be the sort of time
travel where you can't prevent a kind
some sort of Judgment Day from happening
and so this is what the new one maybe
looks like or maybe this is just another
pocket of you know humans versus Skynet
resistance either way it's definitely
working on my nostalgia for seeing our
Melinda Hamilton together yeah that's a
thousand percent working on me because
whenever they're on screen I'm like yeah
now I think for every Terminator movie
every time they're gonna innovate a new
Terminator there's gonna have like a
swatch book because now every terminator
looks like a cross between two I'm like
oh Gabriel Luna looks like the t1000
mixed with the one the chair
in the last movie and then the Mackenzie
Davis looks kind of like mark is right
but also sort of maybe a human I don't
know like hmm so you know they're
they're really keeping those things yeah
there's no doubt about it there's still
some vibes from the ones that follow
Terminator 2 already yeah the only thing
the only thing that does feel very
different is this doesn't feel like as
this feels like an apocalyptic world
that's kind of claustrophobic where the
other two felt very like uh uh Genesis
especially felt like whoa this is a huge
world with like way too much happening
anyway I mean I'm definitely there
opening night regardless yeah even if
this gets like a 2% tomatoes still there
yeah yeah heartbreak that anyway guys
this trailer do it for um do you like
this trailer because it's better than
the first trailer or is the trailer just
good on its own and you're like yeah no
I'm so either answer is okay you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell you can check us
on patreon where we do weekly Q&A s TV
show reaction stream along several with
reaction highlights included thanks for
being here and if anything gets dropped
on the internet that's big I'm not
around to cover it be understanding